mais on est des êtres sociaux on a
besoin de connecter des temps
confinement tout seul dans sa chambre en
plus malade c'est c'est vraiment pas
facile l'une est médecin l'autre
consultante et les deux ont été très
touchés par tous ces patients qui
souffrent loin de leurs proches leur
solution offrir aux hôpitaux des
tablettes électroniques pour faciliter
les contacts entre familles et patients
ça a commencé comme ça ça nous a pris
quatre fois le tour de la ville allait
chercher chez des gens en moi j'en ai
deux camps on s'en va chez vous on se
tient loin howa ipsa ils reçoivent
rapidement de l'aide et des dons et
trois semaines plus tard ils ont déjà
des centaines d'appareils en service
dans une douzaine d'hôpitaux de la
région de montréal
notre but dans le fond c'est vraiment
d'avoir le plus d'appareils possible
pour arriver à soutenir le plus
d'hôpitaux possible la télé ce même émis
la possibilité de faire un projet
pancanadien
on trouve même le câble est aux soins
intensifs ça je vais vous dire ça fait
une grande différence
une grande différence des tablettes
permettent aux professionnels de réunir
les familles et de les préparer au choc
qui les attend donc fait ça avec
beaucoup d'évaluation parce que pas tous
les familles sont capables de voir dans
les membres de famille un tube est très
très critique quand il est sorti d'un
coma de neuf jours c'est d'ailleurs un
de ces appareils qui a permis à cet
homme de reprendre un peu son souffle
jean de facetime pour que je sois
capable de reconnaître les voix familier
pour moi et ça ça beaucoup beaucoup aidé
à me quelle est sa femme jeanne ont
conservée quelle main souvenait très
clairement à être tellement difficile
d'être voit son visage se parler c'est
tout c'est tout c'est ce qu'on a besoin
très bon des réunions de famille une
demande en mariage
pas mal de larmes les tablettes des deux
femmes ont déjà rendu beaucoup de
services
on entend des histoires d'un fainéant
qui nous disent que les passants vont
mourir là qu'ils arrivent à connecter la
famille à travers la tablette pour
qu'ils puissent sauter les derniers mots
donc c'est dur à entendre mais au moins
on contribue à quelque chose de positif
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal